WELL THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALDO GIL
ARCHULETA, ASHBY, ATKINS, BECKER
, BLAKESPEAR, BRADFORD CABALLERO
, DALI, DODD, DURAZO, EGM,
GLASER, GONZALEZ GROVE, HURTADO
JONES, LAIRD LIMÓN MAGUIRE
MANJAR. MIN NEW MIN WEN NILO,
B¢O B¢O PADILLA, PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO, SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALLER
CUEVAS STERN HUMBERG WAHAB
WIENER WIL. MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. I COULD ASK YOU TO
PLEASE GO TO YOUR SEATS. WE'RE
GOING TO START OUR DAY, AND WE'D
LIKE TO HAVE EVERY EVERYBODY IN
THE IN YOUR SEATS, PLEASE. IN
YOUR SEATS, PLEASE. IN YOUR
SEATS. IN YOUR OWN SEATS.
PLEASE. MEMBERS. WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO TODAY AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN DO IT AS
QUIETLY AND AS RESPECTFULLY AS
POSSIBLE. SO WOULD THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BE ON THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN, AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAG. SO LET US REMEMBER THAT WE
ARE ALWAYS IN GOD'S PRESENCE.
GOD OF TRANSFORMING AND ABUNDANT
LOVE. WE TURN THIS MONTH TO THE
HERITAGE AND THE STRUGGLES OF
WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE AGES. AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF OUR OWN
TIME. WE HAVE MUCH TO CELEBRATE.
ESPECIALLY THE WOMEN WE HONOR
TODAY. AND ALL THOSE OF SIMILAR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. WE HAVE MUCH TO
LAMENT. THE LEGACY OF
PATRIARCHY. THE CENTURIES OF
MISOGYNY. THE GENERATIONS OF
FREE LABOR, WHICH GRATEFULLY
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE
FOUNDATIONS OF LIFE AS WE KNOW
IT TODAY. AND WE HAVE MUCH TO
HOPE FOR. ESPECIALLY THE
CONVERSION OF HEART NEEDED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DENIGRATION
OF WOMEN DOES NOT LEAD TO
GREATER FREEDOM, JUSTICE AND
ONGOING CARE OF HUMANITY FOR THE
COMMON GOOD. HAVING COME THIS
FAR AS WOMEN AND MEN OF ALL AGES
, CREEDS, ETHNICITIES AND
ABILITIES. MAY WE CONTINUE TO
UPLIFT EACH OTHER. WITH
ENCOURAGEMENT AND COLLABORATION.
AND ABANDON THOSE NORMS WHICH
SEEK TO DENY GENDER EQUALITY,
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSIVITY. WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO OUR
FLAG. I THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
SO. MEMBERS HERE TODAY TO JOIN
US. UM IT ARE TWO FORMER
SENATORS HANA BETH JACKSON AND
SENATOR BEN WISO. WELCOME TO THE
CHAMBERS.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, SENATOR
PADILLA G. SENATOR PADILLA AT
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
GOOD MORNING WHEN OSTIA SATODA
CDOS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS. MADAM
PRESIDENT, I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THE SENATE IS NOT IN ORDER. I
COULD ASK YOU TO SIT DOWN.
PLEASE. YOU MAY PRESENT. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. I AM HONORED TO
INTRODUCE SOME DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS WITH US HERE TODAY.
CONSUL GENERAL OF MEXICO AND
SACRAMENTO, CHRISTIAN GONZALEZ
AND ACCOMPANYING HIM VIOLETTA
MARGARITA PIN, A SANCHEZ AND
DIDA FANGS. MOST RECENTLY,
CONSUL GONZALEZ SERVED AS THE
CHIEF OF PROTOCOL AND PUBLIC
DIPLOMACY AT THE PERMANENT
MISSION OF MEXICO IN THE UNITED
NATIONS DURING MEXICO'S RECENT
PARTICIPATION AS AN ELECTED
MEMBER OF THE U  N SECURITY
COUNCIL, 21 TO 2022. HE SERVED
AS A SPOKESPERSON AND WAS IN
CHARGE OF DISSEMINATING MEXICO'S
ACTIVITIES, RESULTS AND
POSITIONS AT THE UNITED NATIONS
SECURITY COUNCIL. DURING HIS
TENURE AS A U  N DELEGATE. HE
SERVED AS AN ELECTION OFFICER
FROM 2016 TO 2023, IN WHICH HE
OBTAINED 100% OF THE ELECTED
MEXICAN CANDIDATES IN MORE THAN
40 MULTINATIONAL NOMINATIONS,
WHICH WERE PRESENTED BY MEXICO
AT U  N HEADQUARTERS. BETWEEN
2008 AND 2015. HE REPRESENTED
THE THIRD COMMITTEE OF THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY AS A DELICATE
OF HUMAN RIGHTS, CULTURAL,
SOCIAL. AND HUMANITARIAN
AFFAIRS. AND THIS HONORABLE
POSITION. HE FURTHER SUSTAINED
THE AGENDA PROTECTING CHILDREN,
WOMEN, MIGRANTS, PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. THE L, GB, Tð, Q,
PLUS COMMUNITY AND OTHER
MINORITIES. AS A MEMBER OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS AND CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA,
MEXICO, COOPER OPERATION AND
DIALOGUE. I WELCOME YOU, SIR.
AND YOUR TEAM AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA MEXICO
RELATIONSHIP AND ADDRESS
CRITICAL CHALLENGES FACING THIS
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL
BINATIONAL RELATIONSHIP. OUR
CLOSE PROXIMITY AND SHARE VALUES
HAVE RESULTED IN ONE OF THE
STRONGEST ECONOMIC, CULTURAL AND
SOCIAL REGIONS IN THE WORLD,
OFTEN MISUNDERSTOOD AND FRANKLY
UNDERAPPRECIATED, AND IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE THIS
STRONG RELATIONSHIP. THANK YOU,
SIR, FOR JOINING US TODAY, AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
COLLEAGUES. MADAM PRESIDENT, IF
WE COULD PLEASE GIVE A WARM
SENATE WELCOME AND ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO CONSUL GENERAL
GONZALES.
SENATOR ASHBY. COUNSEL GENERAL,
I WANT TO WELCOME YOU TO
SACRAMENTO BEFORE I HAD THE
HONOR OF SERVING IN THE SENATE.
I SERVED FOR 12 YEARS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL AND REPRESENTED THE
DISTRICT WHERE YOU WILL SPEND
MOST OF YOUR TIME IN A BEAUTIFUL
NEW BUILDING THAT WE WORKED HARD
TO GET TOGETHER. I KNOW THE
INCREDIBLE BOTH HIGH HEELS AND
BIG SHOES BEFORE THOSE HIGH
HEELS THAT YOU HAVE TO FILL IN
COUNCIL GENERALS LILIANA FERRER
AND CARLOS GUTIERREZ TO
INCREDIBLE PARTNERS TO
SACRAMENTO. WONDERFUL
INDIVIDUALS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AS WELL.
WELCOME. I TAKE A PICTURE. FOR
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
PICTURE WITH A CONSUL GENERAL.
OK? MEMBERS WERE READY TO BEGIN
OUR NEXT ITEM. IF WE COULD HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION, PLEASE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE WILL MOVE TO
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER 11. SENATE RESOLUTION 56.
SENATOR SKINNER FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. MR
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 56 BY SENATOR SKINNER
RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH. SENATOR SKINNER. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. IF EVERYBODY
COULD PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION 56 RECOGNIZING
MARCH 2024 AS WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH. S¼ R. 56 ASKS US TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONTRIBUTION OF
WOMEN FOR 31 DAYS OUT OF THE
THREE 166 DAYS. REMEMBER, THIS
IS A LEAP YEAR. WHICH IS LESS
THAN 1/10 OF THE YEAR TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. HALF OF OUR
POPULATION. RESEARCH DONE BY THE
NATIONAL WOMEN'S HISTORY MUSEUM
EXAMINED THE STATUS. OF WOMEN'S
HISTORY. IN THE STATE LEVEL
STANDARDS THAT EACH OF OUR
STATES DEVELOP FOR SOCIAL
STUDIES. THESE STANDARDS
DESCRIBE WHAT STUDENTS ARE
EXPECTED TO KNOW AND BE ABLE TO
DO IT SPECIFIC STAGES OF THEIR
EDUCATION. THE NATIONWIDE STUDY
FOUND THAT WOMEN'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND THEIR STORIES.
WERE BARELY PRESENT. AND OVER
HALF OF THE REFERENCES TO WOMEN,
AND THIS IS IN THE STATE
STANDARDS, SO NÓ MATTER WHAT THE
LEVEL OF GRADE IN ALL DIFFERENT
SOCIAL SCIENCES MORE THAN HALF
OF THE REFERENCES TO WOMEN.
WE'RE REGARDING OUR DOMESTIC
ROLES. NOW I SAID, OUR DOMESTIC
ROLES. OBVIOUSLY DOMESTIC RULES
IS NOT A GENDER SPECIFIC. THINK
AND YET OVER HALF OF THOSE
REFERENCES TOWARDS WOMEN WERE
ONLY ABOUT THEIR DOMESTIC ROLES.
THE ANALYSIS FOUND THAT WOMEN
WERE EXCLUDED BECAUSE STATE
STANDARDS HISTORY FRAMEWORK
GIVES PREFERENCE TO MALE
ORIENTED, EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP
WHILE OVEREMPHASIZING WOMEN'S
DOMESTIC ROLES. WHY DO WE NEED
TO LIFT AN UPLIFT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF WOMEN BOTH
PAST AND PRESENT. BECAUSE WE
STILL EXPERIENCE THINGS LIKE
LAST NIGHT. THE OSCAR SNUB OF
GRETA GERWIG, UH, NOT BEING
NOMINATED AS THE BEST DIRECTOR
FOR, UH, BARBIE. I DON'T SAY
THAT JUST TONGUE IN CHEEK. I'M
BEING QUITE HONEST. BUT WHY WE
NEED TO DO THAT UPLIFTING IS
BECAUSE EACH TIME A GIRL OPENS A
BOOK. AND FINDS A WOMAN LESS
HISTORY, SHE LEARNS THAT SHE IS
WORTH LESS. AND THAT IS A FACT
THAT IS PLAYED OUT DAILY WITH
WOMEN. WE ARE UNDERREPRESENTED
IN POSITIONS OF POWER IN
BUSINESS. IN GOVERNMENT IN
ACADEMIA. IN ENTERTAINMENT. YOU
NAME IT. AND OUR BEING WORTHLESS
IS LITERALLY TRUE. WHITE WOMEN
WORKING FULL TIME YEAR ROUND ARE
PAID 80 CENTS TO THE DOLLAR THAT
A MAN MAKES AND TOMORROW IS
EQUAL PAY DAY. BLACK WOMEN
WORKING FULL TIME YEAR ROUND ARE
PAID 69 CENTS TO THAT DOLLAR.
LATINAS WORKING FULL TIME YEAR
ROUND ARE PAID 57 CENTS. THE
LOWER STATUS OF WOMEN IN OUR
SOCIETY CONTRIBUTES TO OUR HIGH
RATES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THE
DISPARITIES WE EXPERIENCE IN
HEALTH CARE, AND IT CREATES THE
CONTEXT. THE FOUR HOUR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO BODILY
AUTONOMY. A RIGHT I THINK THAT
EVERY SINGLE MAN ON THIS FLOOR
DOESN'T EVEN THINK ABOUT EVER
BEING AT RISK. IT IS SETS THAT
CONTEXT FOR THAT FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT TO BODILY AUTONOMY TO BE
SO EASILY STRIPPED. SO I THANK
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND OTHERS FOR
STANDING STRONG AND ADVOCATING
TO CORRECT THESE GENDER
INEQUITIES. AND IS THIS IS MY
LAST WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH TO
STAND ON THIS FLOOR. I TRUST
THAT ALL OF YOU, BUT ESPECIALLY
MY LEGISLATIVE WOMEN. CAUCUS
COLLEAGUES TO CONTINUE THAT
FIGHT FOR EQUALITY. NOW IN THE
MIDST OF THESE VERY REAL
INEQUITIES THAT I DESCRIBED. WE
ALSO HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS. 2020
THREE WAS A RECORD YEAR FOR THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN RECEIVING THE
NOBEL PRIZE IN DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. STANFORD BASKETBALL
COACH TARA DÂN DEVERE JUST LAST
MONTH BECAME THE HIGHEST GAME
WINNING COLLEGE BASKETBALL COACH
OF ALL TIME. AND CAITLIN CLARK,
THAT BASKETBALL PLAYER. SHE
STEPH CURRY. IN TERMS OF
DIVISION ONE OR EVERYBODY,
ANYBODY. IN DIVISION ONE POINTS
SCORED IN THE THREE POINTERS. WE
ALSO HAVE THE FIRST EMAIL
DIRECTOR LAURIE LESSON OF NASA'S
JET PROPULSION LABORATORY AT
CALTECH. AND OUR OWN. KAMALA
HARRIS IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, THE FIRST
FEMALE VICE PRESIDENT. AND ON
OUR FLOOR TODAY WE WILL BE
HONORING SEVEN CALIFORNIA HER
HISTORY MAKERS. THERE ARE EIGHT
IN YOUR PROGRAM. ONE WAS NOT
ABLE TO JOIN US. WE HAD OTHERS
THAT WE WANTED TO HONOR. AND
THIS IS, OF COURSE, A
REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE WE HAD
SOME IN, UH, TARA VANDERVEER,
FOR EXAMPLE, BECAUSE OF MARCH
MADNESS WAS NOT ABLE TO JOIN US.
UM LAURIE LEN, WHO I MENTIONED
WAS ALSO UNABLE TO JOIN US TODAY
. BECAUSE TODAY IS THE DAY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS RELEASING
THE BUDGET. SHE HAS TO FOLLOW.
PAY ATTENTION TO NASA'S BUDGET.
UM WE WERE ALSO REGRETFULLY
UNABLE TO SECURE F DRESSER
BECAUSE IT'S THE DAY AFTER THE
OSCARS, AND, UH SHE SAID SHE
DIDN'T THINK SHE WOULD, UH BE,
UH, QUITE ABLE TO JUMP ON A
PLANE SINCE SHE'D PROBABLY BE UP
ALL NIGHT AT THE DIFFERENT OSCAR
PARTIES. BUT REGARDLESS WE KNOW
THERE ARE MANY, MANY OTHER HER
HISTORY MAKERS IN CALIFORNIA,
BUT THAT IS NOT TO IN ANY WAY
LESSEN THE INCREDIBLE SEVEN
WOMEN THAT WE HAVE TODAY AS OUR
HISTORY MAKERS FOR THEIR
EXEMPLARY AND TRAILBLAZING
ACHIEVEMENTS. AND BEFORE THEY
GET INTO INTRODUCED. GIVEN MY
INTRODUCTION OF THIS RESOLUTION,
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. SENATOR
CUEVAS. I WOULD CUEVAS. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND GOOD
MORNING COLLEAGUES AND I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HÌ R 72
THAT RECOGNIZES MARCH 2024 AS
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH AS WE
CELEBRATE WOMEN IN AMERICAN
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY,
LET US LIFT UP ALL WOMEN OF
EVERY RACE, ETHNICITY AND E AND
ECONOMIC STATUS FOR THEIR
EXTRAORDINARY RESILIENCE AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STRENGTH
AND SOUL OF THIS GREAT THE WHILE
. OUR STRUGGLES FOR GENDER
EQUITY CONTINUES, WITH
CALIFORNIA WOMEN MAKING ONLY A
FRACTION OF WHAT MEN EARN IS MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE, UH, FROM
BERKELEY LAID OUT WE MUST KNOW
THAT WOMEN ARE FIGHTING FOR AND
WINNING ON ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT,
NOT JUST FOR THEMSELVES, BUT FOR
THEIR FAMILY AND FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THE COURAGE, COURAGEOUS JOURNEY
OF WOMEN WHO HAVE FOUGHT
TIRELESSLY FOR SOCIAL CHANGE.
AND FOR ACTIVISTS WHO NOT JUST
FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS, BUT FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS FOR VOTING RIGHTS
FOR THE DEMAND OF THE PROTECTION
OF OUR BODIES AND THE PEACE AND
SAFETY OF OUR GREAT COUNTRY,
THIS FIGHT HAS BEEN AMPLIFIED IN
THE VOICES OF WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY BY PRODUCING GREATER
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN IN
ELECTED OFFICE AND IN OUR
WORKFORCE, IN FACT, MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR ME TO BE THE SIX
BLACK WOMAN TO EVER BE ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
AND AS THE ONLY BLACK WOMAN IN
THE STATE SENATE. WE STILL HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO TO GET NOT JUST
TO PARITY BUT ALSO TO EQUITY. IT
IS, UH, OUR GREAT HONOR TO STAND
, UH, IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION IN THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
, CONTINUING FIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR VOICES AS WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE HEARD, AND AS WE
RECOGNIZE THESE AMAZING HONOREES
TODAY, LET US ALL IN THIS
CHAMBER REMAIN COMMITTED FOR THE
RIGHTS OF ALL WOMEN. FOR THE
RIGHTS OF OUR WOMEN AND OUR
DAUGHTERS AND THE FUTURE TO
PROTECT THEIR BODIES AND THEIR
AUTONOMY OVER THERE, UH,
REPRODUCTIVE CARE AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FORGE THESE KINDS OF
STORIES AND PASS FOR CHANGE WITH
WOMEN AT THE LEAD, AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. CERTAINLY LIMÓN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. IT'S
MY HONOR TO RISE TO SUPPORT S¼ R
56 WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH IS AN
IMPORTANT TIME FOR US TO
CELEBRATE AND ACKNOWLEDGE THE
VAST CONTRIBUTIONS WOMEN HAVE
MADE TO OUR SOCIETY AND THE
IMPACT THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THROUGH OUR CULTURAL, ECONOMIC
AND CIVIC CONTRIBUTIONS AS A
LATINA AND A MEMBER OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS THAT IS NOW
PROUDLY A MAJORITY LATINA, WITH
NINE SENATORS AND 12 ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR OUR
CAUCUS TO HIGHLIGHT THE IMPACT
OF WOMEN, INCLUDING LATINAS, WHO
ARE PART OF OUR EVERYDAY LIVES.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY 7.8
MILLION LATINAS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY 20. WE ARE
CONSUMERS, BUSINESS OWNERS,
PARENTS, EMPLOYERS AND VOTERS.
IN CALIFORNIA, LATINA OWNED
BUSINESS HAS DOUBLED IN RECENT
YEARS, PROVIDING THAT LATINAS
ARE ENTREPRENEURIAL AND KEY IN
AND KEY AND KEY ECONOMIC ENGINE
IN OUR STATE. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
. WE HAVE MANY LATINAS WHO HAVE
BECOME DISTINGUISHED LEADERS IN
THEIR FIELDS AND CHAMPIONS OF
CHANGE, INCLUDING LABOR LEADER
AND CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST
DOLORES HUERTA. STATES SUPREME
COURT CHIEF JUSTICE PATRICIA
GUERRERO AND FAME RECORDING
ARTIST AND POLITICAL ACTIVIST
JOAN BAEZ. NATIONALLY WE LOOK UP
TO LATINAS SUCH AS JUST JUSTICE
SONIA SOTOMAYOR, ASTRONAUT ELE
OCHOA AND ACTRESS RITA RITA
MORENO. ALL WHO HAVE BEEN TRAIL
BLAZERS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
FIELDS AND CONTINUE TO INSPIRE
GENERATIONS OF LATINAS. BUT OVER
THE YEARS THERE HAVE ALSO BEEN
MANY INSPIRATIONAL LEADERS, WHO
ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED. THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THAT KEEP OUR
ECONOMY RUNNING AND ESPECIALLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THEY ENSURE
THAT FOOD IS ON OUR TABLE. THEY
LOOK AFTER OUR CHILDREN. THEY
ARE TEACHERS IN OUR SCHOOLS,
THEY CREATE NEW BUSINESSES. AND
THEY ARE PART OF THIS STATE AND
OUR COUNTRY. FOR ALL THE WOMEN.
WITH NAMES AND HIGH TITLES AND
WHO DO THE EVERYDAY WORK. THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR STATE. LET US
REMAIN COMMITTED TO THE CHANGE
THAT PROMOTES EQUITY. REDUCES
DISPARITIES AND OPENS DOORS FOR
ALL WHETHER THEY BE POLITICAL,
SOCIAL OR ECONOMIC DOORS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING S¼ R 56.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. UH, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S¼ R 56
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH IS A TIME
FOR US TO REFLECT ON WOMEN IN
OUR LIVES AND IN HISTORY THAT
FOR FAR TOO LONG HAVE BEEN
IGNORED, SIDELINED OR MINIMIZED.
WOMEN HAVE BEEN LEADERS MAKING
INCREDIBLE DIFFERENCE IN ALL OF
OUR LIVES. WE NEED TO HONOR
THEIR WORK THEIR ACHIEVEMENTS
AND RESPECT. LEGACIES AS WE
WITNESS ATTACKS UPON THE BODILY
AUTONOMY OF WOMEN AND SEE A
GROWING WAVE OF POLICIES THAT
SEEK TO CLAW BACK THE STRIDES
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE TOWARDS
EQUALITY. CELEBRATIONS LIKE
THESE BECOME EVEN MORE CRUCIAL.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO EMPHASIZE
WHAT WOMEN HAVE DONE. TO MOVE
THIS STATE IN THIS COUNTRY
FORWARD THIS MONTH. WE REMIND
OURSELVES OF OUR HISTORY OF
TIMES WHEN WOMEN HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM THE NARRATIVES
THAT SHAPE OUR LIVES, WHILE
JEWISH WOMEN HAVE LONG HELD
POSITIONS OF INFLUENCE IN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITIES, THEY HAVE ALSO
BEEN CRUCIAL IN THE BROADER
FIGHT FOR WOMEN'S LIBERATION AND
EQUALITY. ONE WEEK AGO. TODAY
WAS THE FIRST YARD SITE OR THE
ANNIVERSARY OF DEATH OF JUDITH
HUMAN, A LEADER IN THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND A
LEADER IN THE 1977 TAKEOVER OF
SAN FRANCISCO, THE SAN FRANCISCO
FEDERAL BUILDING. TODAY IT WAS
THE LONGEST SIT IN OF A FEDERAL
BUILDING. HER ACTIONS LED TO THE
REENACTMENT OF SECTION 504 OF
THE REHABILITATION ACT, A
PRECURSOR TO THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT. WE CELEBRATE
WOMEN LIKE EISENBERG SEE LOVE, A
DOCTOR OF PHYSICS WHO WAS DENIED
TENURE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA. DESPITE HER
QUALIFICATIONS, SHE FOUGHT TO
BECOME THE SECOND TENURED WOMAN
AT THE UNIVERSITY AND IS
REMEMBERED FOR HER FIERCE
ADVOCACY FOR FEMINIST CAUSES, AS
WELL AS FOR HER SKILL AND LOVE
OF TEACHING. I WOULD ALSO BE
REMISS IF I DID NOT PAY TRIBUTE
TO THE JEWISH WOMAN WHO PAVED
THE WAY FOR ALL WOMEN TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY. WITH THE EQUAL
LEGAL RIGHT TO WHICH THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO AND NOT DEPENDENT ON
POTENTIALLY ABUSIVE PARTNERS.
FOR SURVIVAL. WOMEN LIKE
REPRESENTATIVE BELLA ABZUG, WHO
WROTE THE FIRST LAW BANNING
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN AND
OBTAINING CREDIT LOANS AND
MORTGAGES, OR JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG, WHO ACROSS HER CAREER
ENSURED THE EQUAL RIGHTS OF
WOMEN AND BROKE BARRIERS TO
ALLOW OTHER WOMEN TO FOLLOW
SUIT. I AM PROUD TODAY TO STAND
AMONG MY COLLEAGUES. AN URGENT I
VOTE FOR S¼ R 56 TODAY IN HONOR
AND REMEMBRANCE OF ALL OUR
FOREMOTHERS. THANK YOU. SENATOR
M. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. I'M PROUD TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ R 56, WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH 2024 AS WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH. THIS MONTH. WE
CELEBRATE WOMEN FOR THE
REMARKABLE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
THEY'VE CONTRIBUTED TO OUR STATE
, OUR NATION AND OUR WORLD'S
CONTINUED PROGRESS. NOW, THIS
PARTICULAR RECOGNITION BEGAN
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA LOCALLY
AT THE SONOMA SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
REFLECT ON THE OVERLOOKED
ACHIEVEMENTS OF WOMEN THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY TRANSFORMED
SOCIETY, AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS ON THE MANY PARTICULARS
OF, UH THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
WOMEN HAVE MADE. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO OVER 19 MILLION WOMEN
WERE VITAL TO THE SUCCESSES OF
OUR WORKFORCE AND A BY INDUSTRY.
WOMEN ACCOUNT FOR MORE THAN HALF
OF ALL WORKERS WITH WITHIN,
INCLUDING 74.6. IN EDUCATION AND
HEALTH SERVICES 15 51.9% IN
FINANCIAL ACTIVITIES AND 50.4%
IN HOSPITALITY. NOW. WITHIN THE
ASIAN, AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY. WOMEN ARE
PIVOTAL TO PRESERVING AND
PROMOTING OUR CULTURE AND ARE
VITAL WITHIN PUBLIC SERVICE. I
WANT TO GIVE PARTICULAR NOTE TO,
UH SENATOR AYESHA WAHAB, WHO IS
THE FIRST AFGHAN AMERICAN WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, UH, AS WELL AS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JASMEET BAINS BEING THE FIRST
INDIAN ORIGIN SICK WOMAN ELECTED
AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN, UH, STEPHANIE
NGUYEN, AS THE FIRST FEMALE
VIETNAMESE DEMOCRAT ELECTED TO
THAT BODY. THESE ARE GROUND
BREAKING ACHIEVEMENTS. UH, I
ALSO WANT TO HEARKEN BACK TO MY
OWN CHILDHOOD, UH, GROWING UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES. UH, I
THOUGHT I THINK I INTERNALIZED
THE IDEA THAT, UH, IT WAS NORMAL
FOR WOMEN TO EXPERIENCE
DISCRIMINATION FOR WOMEN OF
COLOR TO EXPERIENCE.
DISCRIMINATION UH, MY MOM WAS,
UH, PROBABLY THE ONLY WOMAN
OFTENTIMES IN THE SEMICONDUCTOR
INDUSTRY IN DIFFERENT BOARDROOMS
. THE ONLY WOMAN OF COLOR THE
ONLY ASIAN AMERICAN AND GROWING
UP II. I THINK I THOUGHT THAT
WAS NORMAL. AND I. I DIDN'T
REALIZE THE EXTENT TO WHICH SHE
WAS A GROUNDBREAKER. ALL THESE
PEOPLE THAT WERE RECOGNIZING
TODAY ARE GROUNDBREAKERS. SO,
UH, I AM PROUD THAT OUR CAUCUS
THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER, SIDE OF CAUCUS CAN
PROUDLY JOIN THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IN CELEBRATING WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH AND THE WOMEN'S
TRAILBLAZERS IN CALIFORNIA STATE
AND I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING S¼ R 56, SENATOR
WAHAB THANK YOU. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE RESOLUTION 56
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH ALL THE
WOMEN IN THIS CHAMBER WE STAND
ON THE SHOULDERS OF EVERY WOMAN
WHO HAS COME BEFORE US. EVERY
WOMAN AROUND THE WORLD WHO
LOOKED AROUND THEIR CONDITIONS
AND THOUGHT WE DESERVE SO MUCH
BETTER. THERE IS A HISTORY OF
CULTURES THAT CENTERED WOMEN AS
THE LEADERS AND CARETAKERS OF
THEIR SOCIETIES. SO THE IDEA OF
WOMEN AS LEADERS IS NOT NEW. IT
HAS JUST BEEN WASHED OVER BY
HISTORIES THAT WANT TO PORTRAY
WOMEN AS WEAK AND TIMID. SO
TODAY I THANK THOSE WOMEN FOR
CREATING A LEGACY OF STRENGTH,
PERSISTENCE AND RESISTANCE. I
STAND BEFORE YOU AS THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN ELECTED
TO THE LEGISLATURE, A MINORITY
AMONGST THE MINORITY. BUT
TOMORROW WE WILL HIT GENDER
PARITY. WE WILL HAVE HOPEFULLY
MORE WOMEN. THAN WE HAVE EVER
HAD BEFORE, AND THAT'S BECAUSE
OF THE LEADERSHIP OF WOMEN LIKE
SENATOR TONY ATKINS. SO I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE. AND, MORE
IMPORTANTLY, YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR MANJAR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ARE RICE THEY ON
BEHALF OF THE L GB Tð Q CAUCUS
ON IN SUPPORT OF S¼ R 57. AMONG
THE WOMEN WE ARE HONORING AND
RECOGNIZING THIS HISTORY MONTH
ARE THE VOICES OF QUEER WOMEN,
MANY OF WHOM ARE THE REASON THAT
L GB Tð Q COMMUNITY HAVE THE
RIGHTS WE ENJOY TODAY. WOMEN
HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE MOVEMENTS SINCE
THE INCEPTION OF OUR COUNTRY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE L GB Tð PLUS
COMMUNITY FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
. IN FACT, OUR CAUCUS WAS
FOUNDED BY FOUR LESBIAN QUEER
WOMEN. IT WAS FOUNDED BY CROYDON
. SHEILA èC, JACKIE GOLDBERG
AND CHRISTINE KEHOE. OTHER
LESBIANS THAT HAVE ACHIEVED SO
MUCH FOR MY RIGHT TO EXIST HERE
ARE AS FOLLOWS MEGAN RAPINOE,
WHO HELPED GET GENDER PARITY FOR
U S¼, A'S WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM,
AND IN FACT, JUST YESTERDAY, I
TRAVELED TO SAN DIEGO TO SEE HER
WOMEN'S U S¼, A TEAM GET THE
GOLD CUP FOR THEIR FIRST EVER.
CONCA CAV, CONCA CV GOLD CUP, UM
AMONGST NORTH AND SOUTH AMERICA.
BILLIE JEAN KING, UM, MADE GREAT
STRIDES FOR GENDER PARITY AS
WELL WHEN IT CAME TO SPORTS.
CORINE JEAN PIERRE IS OUR
PRESIDENT'S PRESS SECRETARY
RIGHT NOW. AND SALLY Kò R, A
ASTRONAUT WHO IS FROM THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. IT WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST LESBIANS IF NOT THE
FIRST LESBIAN TO GO INTO SPACE.
AUDREY LORD, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
POETS, UH, LESBIAN FEMINIST AND
DIANE NIAD, IF YOU HAVEN'T ON
NETFLIX IS YOUR DOCUMENTARY
WHERE SHE BROKE THE RECORD OF
SWIMMING. 111 MILES SWAM FROM
CUBA TO FLORIDA. THESE ARE BUT A
FEW EXCEPTIONAL EXAMPLES OF THE
ROLE WOMEN HAVE QUEER WOMEN HAVE
AND CONTINUE TO MAKE IN THE L GB
Tð Q, PLUS COMMUNITY WOMEN WHO
PIONEERED GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
IN THE UNITED STATES, QUEER
WOMEN WHO CARED FOR THE MEMBERS
DURING, UH THE HÌ. I VÆ AND A I
Dð S¼ CRISIS. THIS BODY, IN FACT
, WILL LOSE TWO LESBIAN
TRAILBLAZERS, THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM STOCKTON AND OUR P Tð
EMERITUS TO LESBIAN SENATORS
THAT I STAND ON TODAY, AND I
HOPE THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THAT THIS ISN'T THE LAST YEAR
THAT WILL HAVE THREE LESBIAN
SENATORS. WE IN THE L GB Tð
COMMUNITY ARE INTERNALLY
GRATEFUL TO OTHER WOMEN WHO ARE
HELPING TO LEAD THE WAY TO A
BETTER TOMORROW AND IT'S A
PERSONAL POINT OF PRIVILEGE IN
THIS MONTH FOR THE FIRST TIME AS
I CAN REMEMBER, UH, THERE ARE
TWO MOVIES IN THE THEATERS RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE LESBIAN THEMED, UM,
AND IT'S SO EXCITING TO SEE THAT
KIND OF REPRESENTATION IN THE
MEDIA. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EYE
VOTE ON S¼ R 56. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TOO JUST WANT TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF US OUR
56 PRIMARILY TO SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE AMAZING
WOMEN THAT WE'RE HONORING HERE
TODAY. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, ALL
THE FACELESS AND NAMELESS WOMEN
WHO WORK EVERY DAY THAT GO
UNRECOGNIZED, AND I KNOW I WOULD
NOT BE STANDING HERE TODAY IF IT
WASN'T FOR MY MOTHER, MY
GRANDMOTHERS, MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHERS WHO HAVE INSTILLED
THE CONFIDENCE AND COURAGE TO DO
WHAT I NEEDED TO DO GROWING UP.
SO I SAY THANK YOU TO HIM. AND
TO QUOTE THE LATE GREAT MARGARET
AFTER IF YOU WANT SOMETHING SAID
YOU ASK A MAN. IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING DONE, YOU ASKED A
WOMAN. WOMEN ARE GETTING THINGS
DONE NOT ONLY THROUGH CALIFORNIA
BUT ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND
ALL ACROSS THIS NATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
SENATOR ALVARADO GILL. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I
RISE TO SHED LIGHT ON AN ASPECT
OF OUR SOCIETY OFTEN NEGLECTED
IN THE ROLE OF WOMEN. THAT'S THE
ROLE OF WOMEN IN AGRICULTURE,
AGRICULTURE FORMS THE BACKBONE
OF OUR CIVILIZATION, PROVIDING
THE SUSTENANCE AND NOURISHMENT
TO BILLIONS AROUND THE GLOBE.
AND BEHIND THIS VITAL SECTOR ARE
THE TIRELESS EFFORTS OF WOMEN
WHO WORK ON FARMS IN THE FIELDS
IN HOUSEHOLDS, ENSURING THAT
FOOD SECURITY AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. DESPITE THEIR
INDISPENSABLE CONTRIBUTIONS,
WOMEN AND AGRICULTURE FACE A
NUMEROUS CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS
FROM LIMITED ACCESS TO LAND AND
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO UNEQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EDUCATION AND
TRAINING. THE HURDLES THAT THEY
ENCOUNTER ARE MANIFOLD AND IN
MANY PARTS OF OUR WORLD CULTURAL
NORMS AND TRADITIONAL GENDER
ROLES, FURTHER EXASPERATE THESE
INEQUALITIES, RELEGATING WOMEN
TO SUBORDINATE POSITIONS WITHIN
THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR. TODAY
WE CAN RISE, AND DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES, WE CAN CELEBRATE
WOMEN IN AGRICULTURE. THEY
DEMONSTRATE THAT REMARKABLE
RESILIENCE THAT SO MANY WOMEN DO
THEIR RESOURCEFULNESS AND
INNOVATION. THEY'RE NOT MERELY
PASSIVE PARTICIPANTS BUT ACTIVE
AGENTS OF CHANGE, DRIVING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTIVITY,
SUSTAINABILITY AND FOOD
SOVEREIGNTY. FROM ADOPTING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND FARMING
PRACTICES TO ADVOCATING FOR
THEIR RIGHTS AND REPRESENTATION.
WOMEN ARE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
SHAPING THE FUTURE OF
AGRICULTURE. IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT
THESE INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS,
AND WE EMPOWER THESE WOMEN IN
THE SECTOR THAT NOT ONLY MATTERS
TO SOCIAL JUSTICE, BUT ALSO FOR
STRATEGIC IMPERATIVE FOR
ACHIEVING FOOD, FOOD, SECURITY,
POVERTY REDUCTION AND
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT. WE MUST
INVEST IN WOMEN'S EDUCATION,
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND
LEADERSHIP OPPORTUNITIES TO
UNLOCK THE FULL POTENTIAL OF
WOMEN IN AGRICULTURE. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SUPPORT THIS
INITIATIVE, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN EYE VOTE. SEEING NÓ
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR SKINNER, YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SO AS WE FIRST THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. AND AS WE CELEBRATE
THE HISTORY MAKERS TODAY AND ALL
OF THE WOMEN WHO HAVE BROKEN
VARIOUS GLASS CEILINGS. AND WHO
HAD TO IN DOING SO, AS GINGER
ROGERS SAID. DO EVERYTHING FRED
ASTAIRE DID BUT BACKWARDS IN A
HIGH HEELS. I ASK YOU TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR US TO ACHIEVE. POWER
AND ALL WOMEN AND GIRLS RIGHTFUL
PLACES NOT ONLY IN THE PRESENT
BUT IN HISTORY AND WITH THAT, I
ASK FOR YOUR IVO. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE, ALVARADO
GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS, IY BECKER. AYE,
BLAKESPEAR. ALL RIGHT, BRADFORD.
HØI CABALLERO AY CORTESI. AYE,
DALLY. AYE, DODD. HØI EDMUND.
AYE, GLAZER. AYE, GONZALEZ. I
GROVE AYE, HURTADO. JONES. AYE,
LAIRD, A LEMON. HØI MCGUIRE. HØI
MANJAR. ALL MEN. AYE, NEWMAN.
ALRIGHTY WHEN ALL NILO ALRIGHT
OCHO B¢O. HIYA. AYE, PORTANTINO.
AYE, ROTH. AYE, RUBIO. AYE,
SEYARTO. UH, SKINNER. A AYE,
STERN. HØI UMBERG AY, WAHAB AYE,
WIENER. HIY WILK. AYE. ICE 38 NÓ
ZERO, THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS NEXT WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO CELEBRATE AND INTRODUCE OUR
HONORED GUESTS THAT WE ARE
RECOGNIZING TODAY AS PART OF OUR
WOMEN'S HER STORY CEREMONY.
READY TO BEGIN. VERY OK? MR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE BEGIN. SENATOR
TONY G. ATKINS SENATE PRESIDENT,
PRO TEMPORE EMERITA, ESCORTED BY
SENATORS ASHBY AND GROVE.
SENATOR TONY G. ATKINS MADE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE HISTORY
WHEN HER COLLEAGUES ELECTED HER
TO BE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY IN
2014, THE FIRST SAN DIEGO AND
FIRST LESBIAN TO HOLD THE
POSITION ELECTED TO THE STATE
SENATE IN 2016. SHE WAS PROBABLY
CHOSEN TO LEAD THE SENATE WHEN
ELECTED IN 2018 AS SENATE
PROCESS PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE
THE FIRST WOMAN AND FIRST OPENLY
L GB Tð Q PERSON TO SERVE IN
THAT ROLE. SENATOR ATKINS HOLDS
THE DISTINCTION OF BEING THE
ONLY WOMAN THE FIRST PERSON IN
150 YEARS AND A THIRD PERSON IN
CALIFORNIA. HISTORY TO SERVE AS
BOTH AS LEADERS OF BOTH HOUSES
IN THE LEGISLATURE. AMONG THE
LANDMARK LEGISLATION CENTER,
ATKINS AUTHORED. WE SEND A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT 10, THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
MADE ABORTION AND CONTRACEPTION
A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. PRIOR TO THE
LEGISLATURE, SENATOR ATKINS
SERVED AS CLINIC SERVICES
DIRECTOR AT THE SAN DIEGO'S
WOMAN CARE HEALTH CENTER. AS AN
AIDE TO FORMER CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER AND SENATOR CHRISTINE
KEHOE AND AS A MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO CITY COUNCIL.
MEMBERS, JUST FOR YOUR
INFORMATION WILL BE TAKING A
GROUP PICTURE AT THE END. SO FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT WANT TO GET IN
A PICTURE. DON'T WORRY. NAI KOBO
RI, ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
CHAMPION, ESCORTED BY SENATORS
GONZALEZ AND DURAZO. NAY AIKO
BURRI BEGAN HER ACTIVISM AT THE
AGE OF NINE AFTER EXPERIENCING
HEALTH RELATED ISSUES TIED TO
POLLUTION IN HER SOUTH LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY. SHE
CO-FOUNDED PEOPLE NA POZOS,
WHICH AIMS TO SECURE SAFE AND
HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS, AND THE
SOUTH CENTRAL YOUTH LEADERSHIP
COALITION, WHICH FOCUSES ON
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM TO HELP
MOBILIZE OUR COMMUNITY AGAINST
DISPROPORTIONATE POLLUTION
BURDEN PRESENT IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS. KARTE WENT DOOR
TO DOOR, HELD MEETINGS AND
RALLIES AND SPOKE AT CITY
COUNCIL MEETINGS. AS A RESULT OF
THESE EFFORTS, BOTH THE LO THE
CITY COUNCIL AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TOOK
ACTION TO PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITY BY ENACTING LIMITS ON
OIL DRILLING AND RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS. HER STORY AND
LEADERSHIP LED TO NAYELI KOBU TE
BEING HONORED WITH THE GOLDMAN
ENVIRONMENTAL PRIZE IN 2022.
MILDRED GARCIA, CHANCELLOR,
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
ESCORTED BY SENATORS W AND
EGMOND. A PIONEERING FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GRADUATE
DOCTOR, MILDRED GARCIA IS THE
FIRST EVER LATINA TO BE NAMED
CHANCELLOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. THE LARGEST
FOURYEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IN THE NATION. AS PART OF
HER DISTINGUISHED CAREER DOCTOR,
GARCIA SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF
CAL STATE FULLERTON FROM 2012 TO
2018 ACHIEVING RECORD
IMPROVEMENTS IN GRADUATION RATES
. SHE ALSO SERVED AS PRESIDENT
OF èC S¼ U DOMINGUEZ HILLS FROM
2007 TO 2012, THE FIRST LATINA
PRESIDENT OF A èC S¼ U CAMPUS.
DURING HER TENURE, SHE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED RETENTION
RATES FOR FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS AT ELIMINATED A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. PRIOR TO HER
APPOINTMENT AT èC S¼ U
CHANCELLOR, DOCTOR GARCIA SERVED
AS PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF STATE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES, MAKING HER THE
FIRST LATINA TO LEAD ONE OF THE
SIX PRESIDENTIALLY BASED HIGHER
EDUCATION ASSOCIATIONS IN
WASHINGTON. Dð èC.
PATRICIA GUERRERO, CHIEF JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
ESCORTED BY SENATORS WAHAB AND
MENJIVAR, A DAUGHTER OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS BORN AND RAISED IN
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY, PATRICIA
GUERRERO MADE HISTORY AS THE
FIRST LATINA NAMED CHIEF JUSTICE
OF CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
PRIOR TO BECOMING CHIEF JUSTICE.
SHE SERVED AS AN ASSOCIATE
JUSTICE IN HER FIRST STATE OF
THE JUDICIARY ADDRESS, CHIEF
JUSTICE GUERRERO HIGHLIGHTED HER
COMMITMENT TO A MORE DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE JUDICIAL BRANCH. SHE
IS A CHAMPION OF THE POWER OF
DEMOCRACY CIVIC LEARNING
INITIATIVE AND HAS BEEN ACTIVE
IN THE JUDGES IN THE CLASSROOM
CIVICS PROGRAM AMONG HER MANY
ACCOLADE. ARE BEING NAMED ONE OF
U S¼, A TODAY'S 2023 WOMEN OF
THE YEAR. THE 2022 BERNARD EW
AND AWARD FOR EXCELLENCE IN THE
ADJUDICATION OF THE LAW AND THE
2023 JUSTICE CRUZ REYNOSO
COMMUNITY SERVICE AWARD MEXICAN
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION.
CHRISTINA HOUSE AWARD WINNING
PHOTOJOURNALIST ESCORTED BY
SENATORS BLAKESPEAR AND LIMÓN.
GROWING UP IN LONG BEACH.
CHRISTINA HOUSE FOUND HER LOVE
FOR PHOTOGRAPHY WHEN, AS A CHILD
, SHE VISITED THE PHILIPPINES,
HER MOTHER'S NATIVE COUNTRY.
THIS LED TO A DEGREE IN
PHOTOGRAPHY FROM CAL STATE
FULLERTON AND 10 YEARS AS A
FREELANCE PHOTOGRAPHER. IN 2017
HOUSE JOINED THE STAFF OF THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES AS A
PHOTOJOURNALIST. AMONG HER MANY
AWARDS HOUSE WON THE 2020 THREE
PULITZER PRIZE FOR FEATURE
PHOTOGRAPHY AND THE 2022 ROBERT
F KENNEDY JOURNALISM AWARD FOR
DOMESTIC PHOTOGRAPHY FOR
HOLLYWOOD'S FINEST, AN INTIMATE
LOOK AT THE LIFE OF A PREGNANT
22 YEAR OLD WOMAN LIVING ON THE
STREET. IN 2021. SHE RECEIVED
THE CLIFF EDOM NÚMERO AWARD AND
IN 2021 NA NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION'S BEST
A PHOTOJOURNALISM AWARD FOR HER
WORK ON GAME CHANGERS, A
CELEBRATION OF WOMEN IN SPORTS.
JEANETTE ROBINSON, FLINT
FOUNDER. BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS. ESCORTED BY SENATORS
SMALLWOOD, CUEVAS AND RUBIO. IN
RESPONSE TO HER OWN BIRTHING
EXPERIENCE. JEANETTE ROBINSON
FLINT FOUNDED AND SERVES AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS, HAVE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF BLACK
WOMEN AND GIRLS. UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP, THE ORGANIZATION
BRINGS FOCUS TO RACIAL
DISPARITIES IMPACTING MATERNAL
AND INFANT MORBIDITY AND
MORTALITY AT ADVANCES, WOMEN
CENTERED COMMUNITY BASED CARE
AND EDUCATES BLACK WOMEN AND
GIRLS ABOUT THE REPRODUCTIVE
JUSTICE ISSUES. HER WORK ON
BLACK, MATERNAL AND INFANT
MORTALITY, HELP CATALYZE A
NATIONAL MOVEMENT. RESULTING IN
NATIONAL AND STATE ACTION TO
ADDRESS THE STARK REALITY THAT
BLACK WOMEN IN AMERICA HAVE MORE
THAN THREE TIMES HIGHER RISK OF
DEATH RELATED TO PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH THAN THEIR WHITE
PEERS. FLINT IS ALSO AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM AND IN OUR OWN VOICE, A
NATIONAL COALITION OF BLACK
WOMEN ADVOCATING FOR
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
MITER BANG AWARD WINNING POET
ESCORTED BY SENATORS OCHO AND
ALVARADO GIL. BORN IN FRESNO,
IT'S AMONG REFUGEES, MITER RANKS
MULTIPLE AWARD WINNING POEMS AND
ANTHOLOGIES DRAW FROM COMMUNITY
FAMILY NATURE AND ASTRONOMY. HER
DEBUT COLLECTION AFTER LAND WON
HER THE PRESTIGIOUS 2017 WALT
WHITMAN FIRST BOOK AWARD FROM
THE ACADEMY OF AMERICAN POETS
RELEASED IN 2022 YELLOW RAIN.
HER BOOK OF DOCUMENTARY, POETRY
AND COLLAGE WAS AWARDED THE
ACADEMY OF AMERICAN POETS. LENO
MARTIAL POETRY PRIZE. THE
AMERICAN BOOK AWARD, THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA BOOK AWARD
AND PLACED BANG AS A PANELIST
FOR THE 2022. PULITZER PRIZE,
POSITIONING HER AMONG THE TOP
POETS IN THE NATION. BANK
TEACHERS IN THE MASTER OF FINE
ARTS PROGRAM IN CREATIVE WRITING
AT FRESNO STATE AND HOLDS A
DEGREE IN ENGLISH FROM U èC.
BERKELEY IN ADDITION TO A MASTER
OF FINE ARTS FROM COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
HONOREES TAKE A PICTURE, AFTER
WHICH THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS
INVITED TO COME FORWARD. AND
THEN THE THIRD PICTURE,
EVERYBODY. SO IF YOU COULD
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THESE
WONDERFUL WOMEN THAT ARE THE
HONOREES FOR THIS YEAR, UM, HER
STORY.
NOW THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS MEMBERS.
MM.
ONE MORE PICTURE WITH WHOEVER
WOULD LIKE TO BE IN THE PHOTO
WITH THE HONOREES. MEMBERS ONE
LAST PICTURE.
YEAH. MEMBERS WERE READY TO GET
STARTED AGAIN. MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES. OF THE FLOOR. HAVE
YOU SIT DOWN AGAIN? I KNOW. I'VE
SAID THIS FOR THREE TIMES NOW,
BUT REALLY. MEMBERS. WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF GUESTS TO INTRODUCE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ALLEN. WE
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME TO THE
SENATE. LAURIE PORTER, WHO'S
HERE IN THE ROTUNDA. SHE'S
CO-FOUNDER OF SMOG CITY BREWING.
SHE'S IN THE GALLERY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SO. WELCOME. AND ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ALBERT Ó GILL
. WE WANT TO WELCOME RETIRED,
RETIRED CALAVERAS COUNTY
SUPERVISOR MARITA CALLOWAY.
WELCOME TO THE SENATE. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON. MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
RED MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED, MOVING ON TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR MARCH 4TH
2024 THROUGH MARCH, 7TH 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. SENATOR SARTO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS TO THE INACTIVE FILE FILE
ITEM 13, WHICH IS THE S¼ èC R
111 FILE ITEM. 14 S¼ èC R 114
FILE ITEM 17 S¼ R 68 AND FILE
ITEM 23 S¼ R 71 THANK YOU. SO
ORDERED. BUT. PURSUANT TO RULE
2910 Dð. THE FOLLOWING RULES ARE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S¼
B 479. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SENATE THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM NUMBER 22 SENATOR BECKER.
BE IT FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
DESK. PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 20 BY
SENATOR BECKER BUT TO SPECIAL
OLYMPICS DAY, SENATOR BECKER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
S¼ èC R 120 DECLARING MARCH
11TH SPECIAL OLYMPICS DAY. OVER
THE NEXT FEW DAYS, ATHLETES AND
THEIR FAMILIES WILL BE MEETING
WITH, UM, UH, YOUR OFFICES TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF
SPECIAL OLYMPICS AND THE
SIGNIFICANCE THAT THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS PLAYS IN THEIR LIVES.
SPECIAL OLYMPICS WERE FOUNDED BY
EUNICE KENNEDY SHRIVER WAS
CREATED AS AN EXCLUSIVE, UH,
INCLUSIVE EVENT THAT ELEVATES
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
SINCE ITS FOUNDING. THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS HAS A GLOBAL REACH OVER
5 MILLION ATHLETES AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN OVER 170 COUNTRIES.
ATHLETES ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN AT LEAST 11 DIFFERENT SPORTS
COMPLETELY FREE. INCLUDING
PREVENTIVE CARE AND HEALTH
SCREENINGS. THE ORGANIZATION IS
ALSO SUPPORTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BY TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF VOLUNTEERS, INCLUDING I'M
SURE SOME OF YOU AND MEMBERS OF
MY OWN FAMILY ARE VOLUNTEERING
AT EVENTS. THROUGH THEIR GUIDING
PILLARS OF SPORTS. UNIFIED
SCHOOLS, PROGRAM AND HEALTH. THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS HARNESSES THE
POWER OF SPORTS TO BRING
ACCESSIBILITY AND INC AND
INCLUSIVITY TO THE FOREGROUND.
I'M HAPPY TO PUT FORWARD S¼ èC
R 120 TO COMMEMORATE THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS AND ALL OF THE ATHLETES
IT EMPOWERS PLAY ON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R 120 THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. SPECIAL OLYMPICS PLAYS
A VERY SPECIAL. UM, UH, ROLE IN
MY LIFE WHEN I THINK ABOUT, UM,
GARAGE CHEEVER, WHO GREW UP WITH
MY CHILDREN, AND, UM, WE TAUGHT
HIM HOW TO DRIVE. AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS FUN TO DO.
èC HÌ P DOESN'T KNOW THAT. BUT
UM, ANYWAYS, IT WAS FUN THEY DO
NOW, BUT IT WAS FUN. I THINK
IT'S PAST THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS OR WHATEVER. AND I
JUST THINK THAT, UM THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF CIVILIAN COMMUNITY HAVE SUCH
INCREDIBLE. UM OFFERINGS IN ARE
JUST TOTALLY BLESSED BY GOD.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT CHLOE
PORTER, WHO IS ONE OF THE MOST
INCREDIBLE YOUNG LADIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY WITH DOWN SYNDROME,
AND, UH, SHE IS AN ASPIRING
ARTIST. SHE ATTENDS LIBERTY OR
EXCUSE ME, UH, SHE ATTENDS
LEGACY HIGH SCHOOL AND SOME OF
HER PAINTINGS OF THE AMERICAN
FLAG AND THOSE THAT SHE WORKS IN
THE WOUNDED HEROES FUND HAVE
GONE FOR 40. 50 $60,000, AND SHE
IS JUST AN INCREDIBLE UH, BRIGHT
HOPE FOR OUR COMMUNITY, SO SHE
JUST JOINED THE SOFTBALL TEAM.
SHE IS ON THE DODGERS TEAM AND
PLAYS A SOFTBALL IN THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS. AND SO I WOULD JUST
ASK YOU ALL TO SUPPORT S¼ èC R
120. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR BECCA YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
AND, UH, AGAIN, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR YOU. UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION?
SAYING NONE ICE 38 NÓ ZERO, THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE. OH, BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THAT'S
RIGHT, SENATOR BECKER, YOU HAVE
SOME INTRODUCTIONS. MADAM
PRESIDENT, UM, A GOOD FORTUNE
TO, UH, HAVE TWO INDIVIDUALS
HERE WHO HELP MAKE THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS RUN. UH, DAVID SOLO,
WHO'S THE PRESIDENT? AND èC E
Ó OF SPECIAL OLYMPICS OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND KELLY
POND, THE PRESIDENT èC E Ó OF
SPECIAL OLYMPICS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM AND THANKING THEM
FOR ALL THEY DO. TO MAKE THE
SPECIAL OLYMPICS POSSIBLE FOR
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ATHLETES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A PHOTO WELL, WE, UH, DO IT
RIGHT AFTER THIS. MEMBERS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN IN THE PHOTO
NOW.
YEAH. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR STERN. AND SENATOR,
SENATOR STERN. YOU HAVE A
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT. AT UH,
SENATOR LIMON'S DESK. SORRY UH,
YES. THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
CLIMATE COMMITTEE IS CONVENING
UPON ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM. 2200
SENATOR AMBER, WE'LL SEE YOU
OVER THERE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR ENBERG. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. IT
IS YOUR LUCKY DAY BECAUSE WE'RE
HOLDING A HEARING IMMEDIATELY
AFTER SESSION IN ROOM 112 IN
THIS BUILDING. SENATOR UH, THANK
YOU, SENATOR UMBERG JUDICIARY
112. IN THE CAPITAL MEMBERS WERE
GONNA RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS THE TIME
FOR AN ADJOURNED MEMORY, SENATOR
JONES THANK YOU, MADAM.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, UH, FOR
JOINING ME TODAY, IN THIS
ADJOURNMENT MEMORY, I RISE TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF BENJAMIN
HARON FROM MY DISTRICT IN KHÓ.
BEN WAS A BRILLIANT AND BRIGHT
SOUL AND AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
ONLY 28 YEARS OLD, HE LOST HIS
LIFE TOO EARLY TO SENSELESS
VIOLENCE. BE WAS A BELOVED SON.
BROTHER AND FRIEND. HE HAS
DESCRIBED TO BE THE GOLDEN
STANDARD BIN WAS SMART, KIND, A
GOOD ATHLETE AND SPENT HIS
ENERGY TRYING TO MAKE THE WORLD
A BETTER PLACE AND HELP OTHERS.
AT HIS VIGIL, MANY REFERRED TO
HIM AS A MINSCH, A YIDDISH WORD
FOR SOMEONE OF HIGH INTEGRITY
AND HONOR. MOTIVATED TO FOLLOW
IN HIS FATHER'S FOOTSTEPS. HE
WENT TO DENTAL SCHOOL. IN A
LETTER TO HØI TO A PROFESSOR BEN
WROTE, QUOTE. I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IMPROVES THE
LIVES OF OTHERS BECAUSE I'VE
LIVED A LIFE OF PRIVILEGE AND
FULL OF OPPORTUNITIES. I KNOW
THAT I AM AT MY BEST AROUND
OTHERS AND THEREFORE MY GOAL OF
FARMING. GENUINE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH MY PATIENTS WILL REMIND ME
WHY I CHOSE THIS PROFESSION. HIS
WORDS ARE TELLING TO THE TYPE OF
MAN THAT HE WAS. BEN CHOSE TO
WORK AS A DENTIST IN ALCOHOL TO
KEEP TO HELP PATIENTS THAT WERE
LESS FORTUNATE THAN HIMSELF. HIS
COMMITMENT TO SERVICE EXTENDED
FAR BEYOND THE WALLS OF HIS
DENTAL PRACTICE AS HE DEDICATED
HIS TIME AND ENERGY TO SERVING
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND EMBRACING THE VALUES OF
TIKKUN OLAM, THE JEWISH
PRINCIPLE OF REPAIRING THE
WORLD. B'S DEATH HAS DEVASTATED
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY. WE MAY
NEVER KNOW THE TRUE MOTIVE THAT
RESULTED IN HIS DEATH. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE REMEMBER WHO
BEN WAS AND THE COUNTLESS LIVES
THAT HE TOUCHED. THE FIRST THING
THE HIROI FAMILY DID TO HONOR
HIS LEGACY IS CREATE A FUND
CALLED HEARTS OVER HATE. WHICH
WILL GO TOWARD HELPING PROMOTE
PEACE AND LOVE. MAY BEN'S NAME
BE FOR MEMORY. LET US HON HONOR
BEN'S MEMORY THIS AFTERNOON NOT
WITH WORDS ALONE, BUT WITH
ACTIONS THAT EMBODY THE VALUES
HE HELD, DEAR KINDNESS. EMPATHY
AND ABOVE ALL LOVE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME IN THIS
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK SO THAT HE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. IF THERE IS NÓ OTHER
BUSINESS, SENATOR MCGUIRE THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
, MADAM PRESIDENT, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS FOR THEIR INCREDIBLY
INSPIRING CEREMONY, UH,
SHOWCASING TRAILBLAZERS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE AND SPECIAL
THANKS TO THE SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY FOR HER INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY. MARCH 14TH 2024 AT 9
A.M. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL 330 AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT 9 A.M.